when it comes to the things you love
most is your weight getting in the way
are your favorite indulgences followed
by needless feelings of crippling guilt
do you find yourself not getting the
same Joy from your once favorite
pastimes it may not be your fault you
may be suffering from chronic mild to
moderate fatness
but you're not alone it is estimated
that 50 to 65 percent of Americans
suffer from moderate to severe fat
goodness the good news is lorcaserin can
help in a recent clinical trial Lord
Catherine reduced fatness and its
symptoms by over 50 percent compared
with Placebo along with improved weight
loss BMI as well as other auxiliary
Health parameters so ask your doctor
today side effects may include a
continued lack of discipline inflated
sense of self-esteem poor eating habits
rebound weight gain future diabetes
Phantom neuropathy and feminism do not
take Lord Catherine if you are pregnant
may become pregnant or are thinking
about pregnancy and or the continuation
of your bloodline at all
Lord Catherine so you can be at your
best
join mug club today for 89 annually to
support content like this and get access
to the entire network ladder with
crowder.com
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
glad to be with you today uh Hey really
quickly let's go to CNN oh look they're
covering absolutely nothing and shocker
that intro was foreshadowing look today
is and I know sometimes it's tough
because it is there's always like a
trend that everyone wants to let's talk
but this is trending but the more
important issue today we'll be talking
about is the agreed upon lie the agreed
upon lie sometimes everything you know
is a lie and what we are dealing with
right now is the UVA race hoax right the
hoaxer is Ziana Bryant who ruined
someone's life a woman Morgan bettinger
for years and by the way some people's
lives are ruined four years after the
fact you may not remember the name of
Darren Wilson hey what was the name of
the man from mattress girl
verifiably false right do you remember
those names comment below
comment below if you remember the names
we remember the name of the story and
then once there's a verdict or there's
something let's say a ruling that takes
place in actual court or once evidence
comes to light you move on or sometimes
the media even still focuses on the LIE
and this is happening a lot right now
with other people in the media I mean
we've just seen it with James O'Keefe we
just saw with Alex Jones you see with
Tucker Carlson but right now this has
happened where the fake victim status
creates real victims and it doesn't
require too many people the agreed upon
lie we'll get into it and also by the
way our own infractions uh Sam from HR
we're going to have to have him here
yeah that's true because there have been
a lot
um yes yes so let me ask you this how
would you what we already asked you
there I was going to ask you how you
would react if you were surrounded by
black lives matter uh protesters in a
car or something something speed bump
but who actually really cares
it's a live show
Monday through Friday 10 a.m Eastern
that's the best time to tune in Friday
of course is on mug club and for those
of you out there who signed up in the
last year prior to mayor in the last 12
months somewhere else
and maybe didn't get your mug and you
want to sign up now and enjoy Nick de
Paulo show in the stand-up specials if
you send proof of purchase for your
subscription to any right leaning
streaming service anyone that exists
send your proof of purchase into Fremont
club atlanta.com we will we'll give you
three months free try it if you don't
like it you can leave Gerald a number
two CEO how are you I'm doing well yeah
I feel like there's gonna I think Sam's
gonna have some strikes against me we'll
see yes he does against everybody I feel
like it's just out of context though
yeah I know context doesn't matter with
you it doesn't well how are you you are
positively Aryan so yeah but you are
immediately guilty I don't think it
should should I move to Argentina and
you know who else is guilty
Tim Kennedy will be hunting you yeah I
don't know I'm just saying you know who
else is uh very very white but it's
because he's a Ginger Ginger so it's
recessive gene who's that well you hear
his theme song yeah
he's here today oh you know I mean you
love him pop Crowder how are you sir I'm
great they can't tell I was once a
ginger though they can't tell I can't
anymore yeah from here no you can't it's
got it's got Scottish glow why do you
lie all this so cute it makes you feel
big it's a shade and uh tomorrow we have
Alex Jones actually yeah which means
good it's an entirely different show but
it's still fun it's a lot of fun almost
completely on Rumble the thing about
Santa Brian is I have she worship
smaller it's like okay look Alex that's
not the theme that we're going with
right now uh Pizza is it me or does Sam
just Sam just look at all of us with
total disgust yes Sam from HR attempts
yeah just just beaten down yeah but the
feeling's mutual it is yes we don't want
to have to hire an HR guy but it sucks
yeah exactly and I don't know why we did
the law no
uh something something something the law
speed dumper other I have no idea before
we go on to that in this week in Biden
so it's going to be a concept show about
the agreed upon lie and what kind of
Lies have created actual victims
throughout your life and this story is
just the recent jumping off point
because it's so egregious before that
speaking of egregious see what I did
there this mom uh because they're not
coming for your kids right has nothing
to do with your children uh is uh seen
in this video sneaking uh her child
children I don't know drag queen Story
Hour here you go come to drag queen
story owl with us
police to protect us
and the secret entrance to avoid the
protest singing and making noise to
drown out the hate outside
we loved listening to Aida HD we had so
much yeah
that kid looks positively beaming yes
exactly I was like there was Nary a
smile to be found we love listening to I
by the way also notice that he's a robot
voice yeah because that mom probably has
an obnoxious smoker voice there's way
too much bass and Bill Withers in that
lead up I mean that was sultry sexy
music it really was and yeah by the way
it was the back door right yes around to
the side of the building almost they're
not coming for your kids there just
happened to be drag queen story hours
and and they're a bunch of white
Suburban women who want to get your kids
to these drag queen story hours and then
if you don't support them guess what
they'll take your kids away and they'll
take them to those story hours anyway
hey it's just a good family fun
what what's the draw is this replacing
clowns is that what is that what's going
on well don't don't give me that out
because you know I hate clowns I know
you hate well everybody hates everybody
hates clowns because they show bright
colors that in nature are meant to
signify Venom poison or danger correct
and we put them around children and by
the way they're not all that different
from drag queens that's that's fair but
maybe we we should be blaming the real
root of the problem and that's clown
that's clowns if clowns weren't so bad
drag queen that's true that is a point
that is a point as I said if it's not
Dame Edna I don't need to say it no that
was your high bar you're absolutely
right I mean you know bad breeds Hitler
right Dad Batiste bad brief Hitler
Batista was bad and so you end up with
worse right and that you end up with the
gravera and then the castle but Batista
was bad right then it got even worse so
the point is clowns lent way to uh
transgender clowns I mean there's not
that much of a difference I couldn't
tell them apart in a lineup it's
difficult no Balloons with the drag
queens oh yes there are now
[Laughter]
another issue here some things in life
are tough right it's tough for the
clowns it's tough for the the drag
queens some things are difficult uh like
Advanced calculus
growing crops in arid regions yeah and
uh reading English from a teleprompter
which brings us to this week in Biden if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump and you ain't
black and we see it here again today in
companies like
I hope I pronounced it right I'm a power
is it AME
I believe that's right yeah I'm a power
Florida small business winner Award
winner or the uh Business Week winner
you won
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or Trump and you
ain't black
first off you see the moment he gives up
and who's operating the teleprompter
Michael J fox
last time I heard someone stutter that
it was nurse ratchet threatening to tell
Billy Babbitt's mother about him getting
late
so he's stuttering and then you have the
teleprompter like it's just I don't know
I mean the camera's shaking and then I'm
sure his teleprompter was shaking I love
the moment he gave up he's like hey
Aaron is
I think he buttons it well when he
messes up he usually gets it leans into
it it's funny but it's that is of the
United States it's unable to read are we
all forgetting that yeah yeah that's
true I mean there's there's two sides of
that coin where he can't read a prompter
and president Donald Trump just refuses
to yes I think Trump actually hacked the
problem but I believe it says hey you
know what I hear this crap let me talk
about this
which is still one of the funniest
things ever when he made fun of the
report like he had he had a cerebral
palsy oh I know
[Laughter]
I know yes you can yes you can this is
the issue right we're going to talk
about even the worst case scenario with
this UVA story and Mrs Bryant I'm going
to screw up today just to let you know
and accidentally say Makaya Bryant just
so you know I'm sorry it's Diana Bryant
yes Ziana Bryant but Makaya Bryant was
the one who was stabbing the girl and
got shot UVA was also another rape
scandal that was false that was covered
by uh Rolling Stone Rolling Stone so uh
forgive me if I get some of the names uh
mixed up here but this is kind of an
important uh an important story because
look
we want to believe that the Press is
looking out for you we want to believe
that they're institutions that we can
trust and the truth is when you see this
and you see a story that is so
verifiably false and it destroys
somebody's life and I'll give you a
timeline here where after Zana Bryant
was proven to be a liar the media still
venerated her after that
I mean keep in mind we can go through a
ton of examples remember Johnny Depp for
six years six years until he had his day
in court but it's an agreed upon lie and
we've seen this throughout our lives
where you you'd like to think well there
must be some truth to it okay some truth
to lockdowns
helping
spread the helping stop the spread
[Music]
foreign
we go through what mattress girl
remember Michael Brown
the agreed this is an agreed upon lie
that is affected not only real life
victims but there have been agreed
[Music]
foreign
um that you can use it as a jumping off
point so this is uh just to give you a
quick breakdown right there was a white
girl at UVA okay in July of 2020 it was
more uh Morgan bettinger Morgan
bettinger and uh the story was that she
threatened black lives matter protesters
threatened to kill them right this
person had to deal with ramifications
that were incredibly severe stalking
death threats doxing and the person who
was the perpetrator here
um very large perpetrator Ziana Bryant
fabricate it all we know this now
uh well and let me give you I guess
before we get to all of the disproving
evidence let me provide you with and by
the way hit the share button comment
like whatever it is if you're watching
on YouTube because they desperately
don't want you
to know this just like Michael Brown
hands up don't shoot that wasn't agreed
upon lie right we don't the court
records show it yeah
before we get to what disproves this
story
and I want you to actually pray for the
real victim in this Morgan bettinger I
want you to pray for the real victims
who were vilified wrongfully
uh let's get to the only proof that was
used as the Catalyst for ruining this
person's lives this is the only evidence
regarding this story at UVA from Ziana
Bryant to become celebrity black lives
matter activist du jour this was the
only evidence
she said that foreign
[Applause]
what you gonna push the car
[Music]
hey
now here's the problem there are a few
problems on that very video
you hear threats
yeah none of them coming from Morgan
bettinger the only example of a
Potential Threat that you hear of from
are the people issuing real threats
but that was enough for real life
consequences yeah for Morgan bettinger
exactly and and we'll get into all of
the different details of this case but
it doesn't matter that she's been
exonerated it doesn't matter that what
the voice you heard ooh like questioning
like this is new information is the
person that said that they actually
heard them say it earlier well then why
would you be like oh they said that they
always do this right this is what
happened they say they show you
something and say this is what happened
that you don't see why don't you show
that in other words if she was out there
aggressively saying run them run them
over like speed bumps like I can't
wouldn't there be some footage hey
wouldn't she have her window rolled down
wouldn't she even seem like she's
perturbed presenting some kind of an
aggressive posture you see it from
everybody else yeah claiming it remember
the hands up don't shoot was one of them
remember I mean we could go through uh
race hucksters that ran to that Al sharp
Tamir rice down there yeah who also
can't read prompter apparently the man
said hands oop got
but the racist white officer
shot despite the hands being up
this weekend me so he came to uh Nick
Apollo show last weekend did he no no
not Al Sharpton no dear oh Darren Wilson
oh
yeah I do not like your comedy
I
thought let's not give them any more air
time absolutely irrelevant but he is
hilarious and terrible I don't know we
should have a competition a prompter off
between him and uh former Vice President
Joe Biden so that's fair let's go
through the facts of this case now
because a lot of people are talking
about it but the timeline and why
everything you know is wrong and how it
ties into a lot of uh the agreed upon
lies that affect you so let's go through
fast fact number five all right let's
just go this descending order makes it
easier for you yeah so um bettinger the
girl in question there was accused of
threatening protesters okay all the
evidence you've seen right there that's
it so this is 2020 during the George
Floyd protest uh 19 year olds Anna
Bryant accused bettinger of threatening
to run over protesters uh so
um for reference by the way this is
Diana Bryant okay
so Bryant posted a now deleted tweet
based on that video
saying share slash spread this caps
trigger warning the woman in this truck
approached protesters in Charlottesville
and told us that we would make quote
good speed bumps mind you a protester
was killed by a man in Charlottesville
during the a12 rally in 2017. speed
bumps don't generally require grappling
hooks okay Brian again for reference
this is Diana Bryan
there you go you can
was she in our opening speed bumps
that'd be a wall for Crash Test Dummies
now Bryant then doxed bettinger yeah
before we get to the ramifications of
betting or having to deal with at school
uh the hell which is Hell uh this woman
has been identified as Morgan Elise
bettinger and she goes to UVA so that's
how this starts that video share spread
trigger warning the video doesn't show
what I say is in there it does show me
doing some stuff but you know but
believe what it is that I say in the
media was so desperate at this point
remember this is the same media hey
largely peaceful protests while there
were Flames coming out of the back of
the guy's head
upon lie they they don't care as long as
everyone agrees upon the LIE then men
can be women and women can be men and
the violent rioters can be peaceful
protesters and this girl who did nothing
wrong who was not seen on camera
threatening anybody can have her life
ruined by the person who was involved
with actual threats by the way smash the
rumble button hit like if you're
watching right now because the
algorithms don't give it okay by the way
I just want to go back to this even if
she said that yeah even if like just
okay so let me just concede your point
for a second have we not all wondered
when going through kind of this Riot
season like how do I get out of this yep
everybody maybe it said sarcastic I
installed a push bumper on my car
exactly right so I'm not saying that you
should do that and I understand
Charlottesville and I understand what
happened at the the the a17 rally
um and that's only because the snowplow
was illegal right it's horrific but the
demeanor of the person in the car was
the most non-threatening person so even
if they said that their actions didn't
match it yeah there was no threat yeah
and still you're saying doxing this
person and here's the thing don't
concede that ground I don't care if she
did in other words let's say she did say
you go oh you're surround yeah you know
what you guys would make good speed
bumps out of my way you know it wouldn't
okay they're surrounding the car how
many people have been pulled from their
car had their door ripped from well not
ripped from the hinges I mean it's not
the whole but you get the point the door
was unlocked lock your doors opened
people pulled out in Portland beaten up
what people have the right to say mean
things she has the right to say of
course yeah I think you'd make a good
speed bump make a very large speed bump
but the point is you'd make it but she
didn't even say that the standard
of perfection is so high for people like
betting her it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what you do and it gets it gets
worse when you see the University's
reactions right so this brings us to
fast fact number four I guess just the
timeline uh these accusations ruined
This Woman's life yeah the fake victim
the very large fake victim Bryant and I
say this because also big and beautiful
is part of the messaging uh so it's
relevant uh Bryant
ruined someone's life creating a real
victim so this person went on a crusade
Bryant did uh in order to get a
bettinger suspended not long after the
event tweeted email email these UVA
Deans now to demand that Morgan faced
consequences for her actions and that
UVA stopped graduating racists wait wait
wait wait wait wait there were white
people in the video yes at the very
least she's an equal opportunity speed
bumpist exactly
yes where do you get racism from notice
by the way I don't think they do have
diversity in Crash Test Dummies I'm
pretty sure they're all white they're
all white yeah in fact yeah and that's
not fair at all did you have those toys
as a kid the crash test dummies no I had
real toys oh I had crush it to me
now the crash test dummies need to be
female versions too yes yes yes yes yeah
they break more easily and don't be
ableist they're also they're also worse
drivers the crash test dummies yeah
the CPR dummies yeah they're changing
those over too baby worst drivers their
whole life is running into walls well
yeah but that's the point they have to
create scenarios that would seem more
realistic for a female which is all the
point is it's it's the Inception of
crash tests the crashes are more
devastating yes they're more devastating
cell phone goes yeah exactly has a phone
in her hand like I don't care about
Brian with a Brian is a speed bump you'd
need an all-wheel drive vehicle yes you
would it's neighbors it's pretty tank
maybe I don't know you'd need a raised
truck so it seems to be so let's UVA
stop graduating racist now here's the
thing that's also important
Bryant knows this is a lie
it's been proven Bryant knows it's a lie
says it anyway
not all removes but basically releases a
doctored clip yeah and then uses what
she knows as a lie to get this person's
life destroyed because Bryant knows the
media won't care anyway the media is not
going to fact check it the media wants
that lie as long as they want that lie
then it's convenient so benninger of
course was started with being shunned at
school stalked in her hometown the
director of benninger's philosophy and
law program sent out the following email
listen to this which think about this
this is your professor yeah this is like
this is like that uh that uh giant Face
Lady In The Warriors putting the hit out
on them as they start bopping their way
to Coney and doing it to all the gangs
this is the law professor right here so
now this following email which is
basically saying hey the rest of you
students it's open season on this person
professor said regardless of whether
your classmate
regardless of whether your classmate
made the remark now
that's the whole regardless of whether
it happened did it happen it should
probably start there let's start with
that because whether the person made the
remark or not well first off if they
didn't no email would be sent
this is how you know it's an agreed upon
life regardless of whether it was said
or not or there's any evidence or not
I'm about to Signal my virtue because
I'm a prick regardless of whether your
classmate made the remark and whatever
one's views on the legal limits of free
speech also no aren't you a law
professor
you don't have views on legal limits
there are either legal limits or not
legal limits on Free Speech sorry it's
philosophy and law which means that none
of it matters it's true because they
could teach the law but then the
philosophy portion of them just says or
whatever
and I believe this professor would
normally have started with irregardless
yes irregardless that's besides the
points that's right irregardless
and respective
I need to read this regardless of
whether your classmate made the remark
okay means this is a lie and whatever
one's views on the legal limits of free
speech Lies coming it's substance and
import must be unconditionally condemned
what substance if it wasn't sent or if
it's protected by Free Speech wow none
of this it wasn't said and if it had
been said it would be protected under
Free Speech regardless of opinion yes
goes on to say no academic institution
or program dedicated to free and open
reflection I guess that's your opinion
man on our deepest public disagreements
can condone such an attitude What
attitude think of I mean do you guys see
the comment below do you guys see the
lie here how does they don't care they
don't think that you care they don't
care regardless of whether it was said
or not and regardless of whether this
person actually has done anything wrong
whatsoever the attitude of this person
must be condemned
there'll be twenty thousand dollars for
this question yes consultation look just
put yourself off in this position so she
pulls out I'm going to give you the kind
of the story of what happened here right
we're going to talk about it a little
later she pulls up to this crowd there's
there's some things that happen she
backs away she calls the police to come
because this crowd comes around her car
then goes home she's shaken by the
experience with thinking oh God I'm glad
I avoided a big problem here I thought
she was shaken because uh Zion was
taking a step class over here
lives in the apartment above her um so a
very dangerous place she she goes home
and one of her friends I think the next
day excuse me or that night text her and
says hey are you okay and she's like
what do you mean and she's like well we
heard like friend from back home like
well this is this yeah close town right
in Charlotte Charlottesville he said are
you okay we've heard about this every
student heard about this yes all of the
students all of her friends outside of
the University are hearing about this it
is spreading like wildfire and all of a
sudden you're being accused of something
that you cannot prove that you did not
do you just say there's no evidence it
can be eventually it was proven that
it's not well but at this point in time
you can't right exactly you can't
comment you cannot fight and here's the
thing everybody's against you even if
Morgan had all the evidence right there
yeah no one would have provided it
anyway yet a law professor saying look
you think the law professor would say
hold on a second I have written
statements I have witnesses I have G I
have a Geo tracking in your car oh wait
a second I have an alibi well regardless
of all of that right you still should be
condemned sister
she described the crop the mob on the
9-1-1 call and it's probably probably
racist yes yes well that's true you
describe who's rocking your car uh I'd
rather not large people yes they're
yelling for crying out loud I mean
anyway this is the same this is the same
media who when OJ was killing every
single person in Los Angeles maybe I
don't know pretty good football player
so uh bettinger the girl the victim the
actual victim was referred to a
university Judiciary Committee and was
sentenced to now this is before there
was any process any due process or
evidence 50 hours community service with
a social justice organization
meeting about police community relations
her dad's a next cop by the way at this
time he was a cop I think she
understands police community relations
pretty well maybe doesn't need to go to
a class and then an apology letter to
Brian here's the problem too is that
you'll deal with right in this industry
you'll have publicist go look just
apologize do you have any idea how
painful would be for bettinger to
apologize when she knows that she didn't
do it yes but you would have advisors
people at school saying look if you just
apologize she has a choice of
apologizing for something she didn't do
and being labeled a racist and a
potential criminal for the rest of her
life or fighting back against a media
who will never listen to her anyway
professors who will never listen to her
anyway with the truth the lie if it's
agreed upon will get to you before the
truth yeah this girl's Plans by the way
to attend law school they were
completely ruined right completely
ruined she was actually part of the
sanctions was she was uh she was
expelled from the school but it was
withheld meaning that it's basically
like you this is your warning if you do
anything even remotely close to this and
you don't complete these prescribed
steps yeah then you are kicked out of
the University as a I believe a senior
right no refund UVA is a top school what
I want to see is Michigan maybe an Ivy
League school reach out and say hey
you're welcome here they never would how
about a scholarship of course they never
would I know but somebody's got to have
a swinging Satchel mattress girl gets a
book deal yeah we should find this girl
and get her on the show mattress girl no
no no no not that I hear she did a video
and that's not a good thing well thank
God's Anna Bryant and oh God not a wide
angle no yeah that's true we have the
loading duck oh by the way the only part
that's Photoshop is a Big Gulp again
also also proud of being big and
beautiful because hey that creates real
victims too if girls say hey I can be
like that
we think that it's more harmful for
young girls to want to look like a
Barbie doll as far as figure than it is
for them to want to look like lizzo or
Zan O'Brien think about that again it's
an agreed upon lie that hurts actual
people now here's the thing in the
absence of evidence even though in this
case we had the video footage
um you would have to go to all right
what is the sources of this information
that's the typical process right right
if you're actually going through due
process you have people who win in court
and people still believe the lies about
them that happens all the time right for
example some people still believe that
Alex Jones didn't hand over the
financials to his company he did yeah
they said we want you to specifically
handle handle the financials and say how
much money you made off of your
conspiracies of Sandy Hook and we need
you to do that through the Alexa uh
Google rankings here well that's not
really something I can't actually
quantify that like I don't we're talking
about it for like 16 minutes like you
can't do it so I said ah you're not
disclosing the finances some people
still believe that right some people
still believe that Alex Jones for
example was just a performance artist
out there saying stuff he doesn't
believe okay show of hands everyone here
has been around Alex Jones is Alex Jones
off air exactly what you would expect
them to be yes
exactly to an alarming but adorable
degree he's such a nice guy he's he
really does he's a big heart and no
impulse control
let's go back to uh the motive could
there be all right so this brings us to
an important key fact number three fan
of Ryan the person in question who lied
and went on a campaign and got very
famous by the way
um is a known leftist social justice
Warrior no activist here is Bryant
speaking just eight months ago but I
also think of myself as a 12 year old
black girl who is just marching what
feels like yesterday for Trayvon Martin
um
several 12 year old black girls like
Little Rascals in a trench coat I think
of myself as a young black girl who's
leading the youth choir at my church
well that's good and including
cholesterol and vacation bible school
and the Usher Ministry and all of those
things I think of myself as a young
black girl who was in that space just
learning how to use my voice I'm a
Christian I lead choir but something
about bearing false witness against a
neighbor I don't give a
what about and also by the way I'm just
an interesting bro what about all those
what about all those people you rolled
over Bryant yeah
Bangarang my ass
is there for your actions Bryant was
also instrumental Kaepernick was a good
guy by the way Brian was also
instrumental in getting the Robert E Lee
statue removed from Charlottesville ah
my name is Diana Bryant
I am a student from Charlottesville and
I wrote the original petition in 2016 to
remove the Robert E Lee statue
and she's out of breath it's like a UFC
stare down
I want to first start by honoring the
ancestors and my own personal family
because they are the shoulders that I
stand on you couldn't stand on Brian
Shaw's shoulders
pick it up it's a solid reference
squat suit
[Laughter]
okay it's because this matters this is
someone who's whose entire reason for
being is to be a professional victim
right and needed one key story right you
need one key story Amber Heard needed
one key story Tucker Carlson the book I
needed one key story with with Donald
Trump that media needed one key story
right you need at least one whether it's
true or not Bryant was also panelist by
the way to Bernie Sanders Town Hall so
it's a son who was an actual political
activist yeah absolutely and and I just
want you to understand the timeline so
she wrote that article in 2016 or the
brief I think is what she called it in
2016 in 2017 you had the Charlottesville
issue do you remember what the
Charlottesville issue was about where he
said there were fine people on both
sides right it's about taking down
statues right taking down a statue of
Robert E Lee
was so important around the country that
no matter like I'm not blaming her for
what happened there don't get me wrong
but I'm saying that sometimes your
actions do have unintended consequences
right and people were out saying hey
this is really stupid to take down
statues that doesn't really solve the
problem in the United States because
where is it going to end Abraham Lincoln
whoops I guess we got that far just
about right so yeah we did yeah we did
so I think that's important to
understand that this is what kind of set
her on that famed trajectory yes right
so she's being written about this is her
whole life right now and this walks
right into her hand and by the way the
same thing with Rachel dolezel just keep
in mind was it the NAACP for years
before we found out that she was as
white as Sean King
[Laughter]
and by the way it had to become so
undeniable at that point in time this
show was not very big I remember when I
was talking about Sean King's what
people said what do you mean here's a
picture exhibit a here he is as a kid
he's white exhibit B his dad he's I mean
white parents white siblings here they
are saying that we're white here he is
as a white guy people going that's not
true that's not true and I remember
being at a feminist film festival in
Grand Rapids I'm saying there's no way
that's true it has to get to the point
where it is so absolutely irrefutable
that they just and then your best case
scenario
is they move on yeah is they move on
they don't tell the truth when it's so
damn why does anyone want to highlight
the fact that they themselves were lying
no or wrong because they're journalists
and they're supposed to do their job
every single one of these cases and
we'll list some that are very popular
examples and we've kind of rattled a few
off already even when the truth comes
out yeah nobody cares everybody is moved
on because I don't cover it with the
same Zeal the same that's right wall to
wall coverage remember when Trayvon they
edited the clip of the call where it
made it made him say Zimmerman he's
black and it was like but you edited out
the part where the 911 operator
specifically asked yes if that person
are they are they white are they black
are they Asian he's black they edited
that I think he was speaking Asian they
were Asian name that movie line comment
below or in the chat uh but and then it
leaves wreckage in life tons of wreckage
never go back and correct it doesn't
matter it can never go back you won't
see the headlines even if they go back
and correct it completely right nobody
will care that's the person who did this
that's all I remember Well here here's a
key factor obviously number two which
brings us to the whole thing was a
verifiable lie now let me tell you
because this is something that again the
media is not covering and Morgan's life
is still ruined
so in June 2021 a separate investigation
by uva's I need to read this right
office for equal opportunity and civil
rights the eocr I already don't like it
but but they said not only found that
bettinger didn't legally harass Bryant
but it painted a picture of just how
shaky Bryant's allegations were yeah at
least four of the five allegations by
Bryant against benninger were deemed to
be completely false lies betting her to
be clear was heard on the tape here's
what also matters right when there are
when there are moments that bettinger
speaks oh you can hear what she's you
can hear what she's saying so she didn't
say what they said she said but then
they when they go unintelligible they
insert it and say that's what she was
saying she was going to come she was
going to burn a cross in my yard and
and I was like why you better not
you better not she was like I is like
that's all under unintelligible yeah
you're damn right that's a lot of
unintelligible by the way they don't
have her bettinger's statement
originally on this they don't have that
on tape what she said originally that
she's going to quote here they don't
even have that no just what people said
next right that's what but she is heard
only heard on the tapes mentioning speed
bumps in one comment okay and the
comment is it's a good thing you are
here because otherwise these people
would have been speed bumps yes
referring to someone else Good Samaritan
well it was the city worker so city
workers a truck driver by the way who
was blocking the road he drove up to an
intersection that was blocked by a City
truck but it was only partially blocked
and so she thought okay well maybe he's
doing some work right there and they're
using the truck as cover and so she
slows down she goes around she gets to
the end of a block and she sees people
in the road so she pulls over in parks
and gets out of her car to see what's
going on she's kind of confused she's
like I have no idea what's Happening
Here gets back in her car but doesn't
have enough room to turn around and
starts reversing and that's when the
crowd starts coming after her what she
did is she went over to the truck driver
and said hey I'm glad that you are here
otherwise these people would become
speed bumps in other words I'm glad
you're here otherwise I wouldn't have
been able to know and would have
accidentally run over people thank God I
didn't right that is that a reason for a
life to be ruined is that a reason for a
law to a law degree to just be put on
hold potentially never pursued genuinely
I want if it could happen to any of you
it could happen to any one of you you
think Morgan bettinger expected this
comment below no so she's she's
completely reinstated Gerald is a senior
at UVA law school she was but with those
so the things that we read off her she
had to go through that training so the
student body has kind of this Justice
counsel essentially that goes through
this process here's the terrifying part
to this it's made up of students they've
all heard that she's a racist they've
all heard that she said people should be
speed bumps right that that life there's
a diverse it's lord of the black flies
it pretty much is her lawyer said that
there are instructions that the universe
diversity gives specifically to the
council to make sure that they don't
come back with the wrong decision
because that can actually because UVA is
a State University it's the state
imposing their will on your right to
free speech and there's some legal
ramifications to that they didn't give
the right kind of instructions for this
they left it open and the students said
we agree that you said what you think
you said to the driver but you should
have known using the word speed bumps
right was going to be a threat I'm not
even kidding we agree with the situation
as you have explained it to us right but
you're still in the wrong right
unbelievable it really that well it's
totally believable but I understand what
you're saying it shouldn't it shouldn't
be possible and by the way back in
school or not she went to school she
graduated from there but now she works a
job in Charlottesville because no law
school is really wanted to take her and
she doesn't disclose where she lives
because she has fear that she will be
railroaded again yeah and you know what
happens good people don't want to be
included for commentary very often right
it's really this is what you notice it's
really easy to find people who are
clamoring for fame people who weren't
there people who didn't hear it
disgruntled employees form former
friends former lovers this is always
what you're with Donald Trump right it's
someone who was a former was a former
lover someone who he had sex with once
or a relationship gone sour this happens
all the time or they bring out someone
who says oh he ruined my condo and I was
a black guy they don't bring out people
who have worked for them forever they
don't bring out the people who are
actually there they don't actually take
into account when it's a tribunal the
truck driver who heard exactly what was
said the equal opportunity in civil
rights office by the way of the school
which is a silly name and it's a stupid
thing even found that Bryant couldn't
have heard the comments firsthand okay
allegations are false they acknowledge
it and there's no way Bryant could have
heard it firsthand which by the way puts
a different context what that means is
that bright light yes what that means
when Brian said you said we're going to
be Speed box right
they we know she could have never heard
that it's not possible which means she
was lying at that moment in time run a
camera I'm gonna say something I'm gonna
be famous which by the way has happened
in my own life I've had people turn on
cameras when I'm picking up remember at
CVS the one time turn on the camera yeah
what about uh what about Vox you want to
call someone and I just come thank you
have a nice day because they want to put
you they want to put you on I don't want
to say world star but they want to put
you on Tick Tock it happens all the time
okay hey have a nice day things that you
would never accept in your day-to-day
life
I'm gonna be famous what'd you say you
say you want us to be speed bumps how
scared do you think that woman is
surrounded right now you think she's
seen a video of Reginald Denny he thinks
she thinks that there's going to be
anyone willing to risk their neck for
for a white girl in a car who everyone
else is accusing of being a racist just
to note all of these findings were in
June of 2021 that's key okay June of
2021 because even after the closest
thing you get to court which is this
weird tribunal in school that is stupid
but that's the closest thing that you'd
have to Justice even by those standards
okay we now already know the truth
Morgan didn't do it it's not possible
right that's June 2021 July 2021
Washington Post wrote a glowing profile
piece on Brian anyway titled the girl
who brought down a statue how about the
girl who lied and ruined someone else's
life liar liar and you know
it but
so he's been sitting on it and then in
September 2022 again keep in mind we
know beyond any shadow of a doubt that's
Anna Brian lied that video was false
Ebony magazine listed Brian on its power
100 list took up four spots
[Laughter]
yeah absolutely and by the way after all
of this after that report comes out the
president I believe it's the president
it was one of the the administrators at
the very top it could have been a
Provost or something like that maybe a
different name but the president of UVA
says that he's not going to overturn
what happened in the the council meeting
essentially and not come out and say
anything about this and not issue a
report exonerating this person and by
the way how much do you think it helped
her to comment on yes but Bennett right
Morgan I think her last name is
bettinger bettinger thank you Morgan
bettinger when they came to her for
comment how do you think they cared
right I think they cared in the article
was the headline still the same they
came here's the kind of thing they do
they go to Morgan bettinger for comment
and say
um do you apologize for uh referring to
these people as speed bumps yeah and
here's the thing part of that is true in
other words if you're more embeddinger
you'd have to answer hold on a second I
said to a truck driver thank God you
were here otherwise these people could
have been speed bumps because I I'm so
glad that I didn't accidentally run them
over so you did refer to them as speed
bumps thank you and they go off with a
quote exactly this is dishonest
reporting even and and even after even
after it's been proven false but these
news organizations these journalists are
so quick to just run with stories and it
doesn't again it doesn't matter she
wouldn't have been served at all by
commenting on this because they would
have just painted her as the racist UVA
student as they did as they did and this
is also an important I guess this brings
us to kind of effect number number one I
guess kind of launching point for a big
issue that affects all of you and uh by
the way hit uh like if you're in the
show just comment whatever it is you
want to do share mug Club ladder.com
yeah we'll be doing that for another
hour today this is part of a bigger uh
when people say we have a systemically
racist culture no we have a we have a
hoax culture yeah we have a dishonesty
culture right
um we have people there's there's the
court of public opinion and then there's
the courts and by the way that assumes
that you get a non-corrupt judge or that
assumes that let's say the intelligence
Community hasn't stacked against the
deck against you which also takes place
yeah I mean where do you go and find
Justice if you know what's going on at
the CIA and the FBI you know how it's
politicized and you happen to be in a
county where the judge is blue so but
even in those instances where things
were found to be false right against in
the in the courts the court of public
opinion didn't change why because the
LIE travels faster than the truth so
let's go through some examples that you
may have forgotten Jesse smallett you
probably remember well with them you
probably remember it actually happened
because it was so it was so clear right
Bubba Wallace you remember obviously
what happened with NASCAR and Wallace
and that's the news that's called the
Garage pool but okay but those are
important because guess what you did the
job
I I've been here long enough uh when the
show was small you know it was in my den
and then in my garage and then what used
to be an old dirty massage parlor to
where we are now we're back in the day
there wasn't enough uh of an ability to
fight back against for example the
Michael Brown hands up don't shoot right
there wasn't enough of an ability to
fight back against mattress girl we
would cover it but there weren't enough
people but then it changed where you had
people like Jesse smallett Bubba Wallace
because by that point CNN MSNBC New York
Times New York Post right Washington
Post had done this and you switched
spots which is why they're not going
after big Tech because you know those
well and by the way on the Bubba Wallace
story if if in fact check me if I'm
wrong what did they send nine FBI agents
yes that's more than went to investigate
the sexual assault claims against
Michigan State's Nasser what's its name
but less than we're involved in the fake
kidnapping plot to the governor yeah and
and there's probably an equal number
that tried to kind of stage something in
Washington DC where they were all
dressed in the same uniform that one day
I can't remember what the protest was
right the Liberty protesters we call
them glowworms yes exactly but I think
it's about an equal number there but you
may not remember the BYU race heckler
right remember there was a black
volleyball player heckled by racial
slurs that's right yeah but then there
was a view of the game footage nothing
ever occurred well she meant it right
yeah you probably remember if I say
mattress girl
right you remember mattress girl yeah he
was a male student of raping at Columbia
University carried a mattress everywhere
right like it was a cross even to
graduation it was a twin size though so
but let me ask you this the person whose
life was destroyed do you remember his
name
that's not even easy to pronounce
Paul nungister
does that mean no no mattress girl great
story sexy good picture the man who was
never prosecuted the man who did not get
to or young man student who didn't get
to attend his own graduation the man who
by the way afterwards the university had
they had to settle with him after a
three-year legal battle you know his
name
no mattress girl was a story right and
then maybe you even heard that it was
false at some point in time Paul longing
sir if I'm getting the name wrong
forgive me
never got his name cleared that will
follow him for the rest of his life just
like Morgan bettinger she will go for
the rest of her life to some job
interviews and even even though she's
innocent and she's been proven they'll
go I just don't want to you know we
don't wanna we don't want to handle it
hey remember the UVA gang rape hoax
you probably remember right Jackie was a
UVA student who's gang raped in a
fraternity and you may even remember
that it was false
do you remember the names of the men who
were accused
do you know what happened to their lives
do you care
do you think Rolling Stone who had to
settle with a fraternity and have had to
retract the story do you think they care
what about the Duke lacrosse players
right you remember that yeah geez
stripper accused the Duke lacrosse
players of rip now you probably know
that it's false do you remember the
names
what are the names of the men who were
falsely accused
the charges were dropped against all
three and this is rare this is one where
the only reason you know it's false is
because ESPN did a huge story about it
right let everybody know that this was
false years after years after false
again there's the court of public
opinion and then there are the courts
which by the way do you all also don't
always serve Justice you remember the
name Michael Brown this is a big one
right hands up don't shoot genuine
questions some of you how many Americans
do you think
remember the name Darren Wilson
not only shot Brown during a struggle
Wilson was not only found not guilty you
don't know this about Darren Wilson
Darren Wilson the police officer hands
up don't shoot who was being punched who
was having his gun reach for that day
Darren Wilson actually had a pretty easy
beat in the neighborhood and he said you
know what actually I want to go down to
a tougher area of town because black
people there don't trust white cops and
we need to improve this here in Missouri
yeah he he wanted to reach out to the
community and he was actually pretty
well liked by the community
how many Americans know the name of
Darren Wilson
now Nick Sandman you know because you
follow this show but it was a picture
let's bring up that picture if we can of
the smug white boy right who was out
there smiling in the face of uh of of of
black guys let's just whatever it is
black people doesn't really matter Black
Hebrew Israelites who hate all white
people say that you can't go to heaven
whatever he was he was smiling and black
he was wearing a moga hat
remember he called other people
they alleged racial slurs when in fact
they were calling him white cracker
right the F is what he was being
referred to remember Nathan Phillips
turned out he was a professional
protester that toothless meth head
claims to be Native American who shows
up with his drum
that kid Nick salmon defamation
settlements he's won them with CNN NBC
Washington Post and by the way this is
still Kyle Rittenhouse yeah you still
have people out there Kyle written us
who want to murder that kid doesn't
matter what happened in court Johnny
Depp's life was ruined for six years of
his life yeah because he had to White
Knight it and not actually tell you that
a bottle was and by the way alcohol
problem sure a little weird short as you
walk around with 19 bracelets like he's
a little rotating bin and Hot Topic yep
doesn't make him a criminal and you
never get that back by the way you never
get it back and by the way it's still
happening right now you just saw it
happen with James okay and full
disclosure okay I have conflicting
interest with knowing some of these
people so I understand it don't take
what I'm saying uh as completely
objective like James O'Keefe has been on
the show I have had Pleasant
interactions with James O'Keefe we're
not close friends but James O'Keefe
James O'Keefe doesn't get to clear his
name the media you think the media's
ever going to clear his name Tucker
Carlson this is happening with him right
now yeah this is happening with Tucker
Carlson right now with someone he never
even met and that's not going to be
corrected down the line Alex Jones what
you know about the Alex Jones case sure
Alex Jones screwed up he admitted that
he's grew up and apologized a long time
ago regarding Sandy Hook but what you
think about the case is not what was
actually brought out in the case just to
be clear
well and you're actually forgetting one
it's just you oh yes well that's true
and which means by the way you can uh
leave a comment down below I forgot yes
Stephen
oh boy um okay uh yeah
yeah
Sam oh my God she's getting in very
sorry but um I have something to discuss
with you oh god oh right okay
[Music]
all right Sam you do know Sam from H you
do know that we're live right yeah pull
the microphone close you're an HR guy
you're not an audio Guy come on all
right I am aware of that and I am sorry
but I've got a line out the door
um with um infractions to have happened
inside this office we can't we just we
can't just do this as a meeting outside
right now no it just can't wait
you have a list of infractions that have
taken place in this office goodness
sorry Steven but this has to be
addressed okay um all right the other
day everything you're about to say has
actually been spoken in this office yes
that is correct oh boy okay so these are
all and and what's the punishment go go
just yeah so the other day Gary said
quote I have never met a Russian I that
I liked Gary did you actually say that I
did Stephen I'll be honest I'm sorry all
right well okay so we don't appreciate
it all right okay Sam we got that's
really not that bad but he's Russian but
yeah it doesn't matter you can't say
that it's wrong to hate sure all right
Sam okay Kim said when in doubt quote
blame the clintons well okay Kim that's
not dude for crying out really sorry
Stephen you did say that all right well
look people say things in an office
these These are minor infractions I
think so I mean yeah okay and then
toolman said
so we want to talk about this Jewish guy
that steals everyone's money did you say
that yeah I probably this sounds like me
that actually is something that you said
yeah okay let's not he's Jewish let's
not do that and let's talk about Sam yes
okay all right and that now there's this
newspaper article out this morning where
um it says quote Crowder was known to
expose his genitals to staff hold on a
second yeah we'll do yes just wait
I mean that did happen what are you
talking about the Terminator 2 sketch no
but at the time you only had five
employees and they were all male well
yeah I know but is that was a Terminator
two sketch because remember the nudies
didn't fit oh is it that one Sam yeah
well now they're the ET ones uh through
the corn fields where we had to run
naked through yeah naked in that one
yeah we were naked in that one too good
one that was the night though was it gay
Captain America because what happened is
the cold the the onesie didn't fit so we
just had to make it a nosy and there was
no
um well now that there are ladies here
we have to run things differently this
isn't like the Terminator clip well I
know it's not like the Terminator clip
do we have well yeah but there's do we
have the terminated clip play the clip
yeah yeah okay
all right
come with me if you want to learn look
okay of course yes many people saw my
balls Yeah well yeah but I had a sock on
because annuities wouldn't fit you
couldn't do it yeah right yeah you have
a large posterior yes exactly and there
were also times where we played this
about the ball game yeah well uh we need
to stay on topic as well okay
continuing with the infractions Riley
said quote govern Me Harder daddy Riley
oh
Riley said that these aren't all that
bad uh I mean I think I wouldn't get the
hush one your mic isn't really working
all that well um yeah uh I think wait
it's actually hold on a second the game
uh you hit the game button over here oh
okay let me yeah it's right there
is that your testicle yeah it is oh
[Music]
I got him again
that works every time
you know I'm still trying to live down
the fact that Darren Crowder stole the
pace car at Talladega in 86. oh that's
right that's right there was a Darren
Crowder who stole the pace car and
people think that that was you
got a whole lot of the car in my ass
kicked
those state troopers this is this is the
issue we're talking about is the agreed
upon lie where people think oh no we
must what we must be hearing is is true
of Tucker Carlson well must have heard
at UVA with Brian is true I just want
you to go back through and this is
something we've all had to live through
right and this is why as it leads up to
this next election
um do you think it's happened since that
we were banned before the last election
no and it was happen since that we were
banned because of the election before
that because of covering the election uh
you think it's happenstance that Tucker
Carlson is going to
[Music]
please
foreign
[Music]
racist turns out it wasn't yeah you know
what we were wrong we said peaceful
protest turns out billions of dollars in
Damages if you know that it permeates
intelligence communities the White House
it permeates signs it permeates your
very own doctor's office
why wouldn't it permeate media and of
course big Tech or kind of one on the
same
and if there's no incentive for these
other establishments that you mistrust
the institutions it's your fault
what incentive would the media and what
incentive would these Tech organizations
have to correct themselves and tell you
the truth when the LIE has already
traveled quickly and they already have
the focus group saying oh people like to
lie
the problem is the LIE particularly
alive based on this victim status
culture on identity politics creates
actual victims
and we don't know we don't know the
truth about what's going on right now
with a lot of other people what we do
know is hey call Rittenhouse sorry you
deserve better hey Nick Sandman sorry
you deserve better hey Darren Wilson
sorry you deserved better hey Morgan
bettinger big time sorry you certainly
deserved better you're never going to
hear that in the media and you're never
going to see that Amplified on big Tech
unless you do your job and ensure it
don't apologize we're going to talk more
about this of course on mug Club here
for another 45 minutes
don't apologize
Andrew Breitbart remember he said
this is another one remember Andrew
Breitbart let me give you a story about
Andrew Breitbart okay Andrew Breitbart
actually brought in James O'Keefe then
it was James O'Keefe and Hannah Giles
the acorn sting which ended up defunding
a community organizing Group which by
the way Barack Obama was associated with
they were going out there they were
harvesting for there was all there were
all kinds of Nefarious activities going
on with Acorn at the time everyone knew
it you're probably not as familiar with
it today because they're no longer as
relevant so James O'Keefe and Hannah
Giles went in from Acorn office to Acorn
office and they were actually getting
these Community organizers to help them
with underage prostitution bringing
underage prostitutes right in under the
radar now what happened you can hear the
video you can see the uh sorry see the
video and hear the audio James O'Keefe
and Hannah gel saying could you help us
could you house us right and these
workers saying yeah there are ways to
cover that up there are ways to hide
that on taxes there are ways to you know
a lot of people who thought sex work was
real work now all of this happened Acorn
ended up being defunded to some degree
here's what the media did James O'Keefe
young James O'Keefe made an appearance I
believe on Fox and Friends
or maybe in some videos dressed up as a
pimp and of course he never went into
Acorn dressed up like Kramer the pimp
and Seinfeld none of us were suggesting
that he was this was a portion for the
audience saying we went in as a Pimpin
prostitute but when they went in they
said can you help us pimp out underage
girls and the workers of acorn said yes
the media said this was misleading
because he didn't go in in a fur
coat and after that and there was an
incident with Shirley Sherrod in which
Bill O'Reilly yeah that was what they
said see he didn't do that in acorn it's
a lie what about the fact that they're
helping underage sex trafficking
hey by the way more slaves today than
ever recorded history
42 million good portion of them are sex
slaves instead you condemned the guy
who's trying to do something about it
because the organization has been
running interference for your guy at
that point Barack Obama Andrew Breitbart
after that and something that happened
with Shirley schrod another selectively
edited clip that he had nothing to do
with and he ended up being
totally exonerated in in reality but not
in the court of public opinion you need
to know this Andrew Breitbart after
James O'Keefe after these incidents was
gone
he was down and out
until he had the Anthony Weiner dick
pics that were being sent out to
everybody huge liability I don't know if
you know this for representative and
Anthony Weiner was going out saying this
is not true this is a smear campaign and
the media went with it I remember clear
as day Alec Baldwin went with it people
who were check marks back then who won't
pay for the check mark today went with
it all of the mainstream media went with
it they said oh Anthony Weiner's been
hacked and there are doctored pictures
out there and Andrew Breitbart
professional huckster is looking to go
the only reason the only reason that you
know that was false is because that man
hijacked the podium and said I have the
pictures and because he was a decent man
didn't want to reveal them and Destroy
Anthony Weiner's family
but that is what was required that man
deserved better
and people now all love to act like they
were in his Corner a lot of people
weren't a lot of people threw him under
the bus who were in positions of power
even on our so-called side he had to
live through that that man deserves an
apology and deserves better and one of
my favorite he said when he was asked
would you apologize would you for
something that he knew the media was
lying about he said apologize for what
that needs to be apologized for what
you deserve better these people deserve
better the media big Tech who lie about
it because the LIE is sexier than the
truth and they have no incentive to ever
fix it
these people
let's go to Buck club and we'll talk
more about it piss off YouTube
[Music]
foreign